you look fantastic as always you really
do i really try for this show
i really do but you make more of an
effort for archery i really do
i this means a lot to me to be here so i
tried to look
as wet as possible that's like the new
look as wet as you might be on the
inside on the outside
that is the makeup trend dewey is it
real is it
dude that's the way it's real people
seem to be agreeing with you that that's
wet like look like you're you're trying
look amphibious
like i got jealous of a salamander the
other day i'm like what is she doing
because you are and it works because
people like i
spray stuff on my face at the end of my
makeup to give it like a wet look
and um and people are tricked like
you'll wear it out and guys don't know
makeup so they'll just be like nikki
you're glowing and i'm just like yeah i
sprayed a varnish on my face that's
usually used to steal
dicks it's not some sort of inner like
radiance
i'm really sad yeah yeah yeah yeah well
they ever just think you're sweaty yeah
yeah
if i did that people would think i was
having a heart attack
they would they would you know i uh you
uh i you talk about this all the time
when you come on our show you talk about
your your struggles
in your dating life yeah i always say
i'm shocked because you're i find you
you're a very attractive and talented
person but you're
there you are you're on uh are you on
the dating apps because there's like
because there used to be just regular
dating apps now i'm told
i'm just told that uh there's a
celebrity dating app there is it's
called raya
raya okay and you gotta be a celebrity
you don't need to be
like there i it's there's a couple
celebrities here and there i'm on it
just like to find ben affleck i'm just
swiping for benny boy
i like a guy who's going through
something you know do you think he's on
you don't think he's on it is he on it
i'm not allowed to say because i want to
stay on but
he may be right you know there's like
rumblings like guess who just gone on
you know so
um i got on accidentally i just want to
say that now
you're just there i was there for three
months accidentally
yeah it's but it's mainly just like dj's
jumping off of yachts like that's kind
of what it is
it's just guys vacationing too much
you're really confused about what they
do for work
but every every single guy they everyone
men look terrible on dating apps and i
don't
i i've like swiped left on guys that
i've slept with before and been like i
would never and he's like you did
like i you guys look terrible on these
because they're all based on pictures
men don't take pictures of themselves
right and you don't have guy friends
helping you out that's why women killed
on these apps we have so many pictures
of ourselves
our girlfriends are constantly helping
us out guys don't have guy friends being
like
dude you look so hot right now like just
stand still like the way the sun is
hitting your eyes
just you're right we're all this
sunbrella real quick like
no one's healthy andy has never done
that lick your lips
that is a good look for you yeah you
need to you need to help each other
because you look
so stupid on these apps there's a
classic picture that every guy does
where he's at a wedding and which is
actually the best picture you're gonna
have of yourself not your own but like
um that would be a bad look but uh this
is my
dating action here i am with my wife on
the day we got married
bride's face blurred out yeah well he is
marriage material he's done it before
um but no it's like a guy like at a
wedding a lot of guys post this picture
where they're like
doing some kind of signature dance move
that they're like known for but it
really means they don't have a
personality and so
they've built one around being able to
do the worm in college
and so and no one likes the worm guy
ever but it's always this picture where
he's like
and there's a beer stain on his shirt
and you think you're putting that out
there like
i'm the life of the party but really i
see that i'm like
you're the liability of the party like
you haven't been doing arms lately you
can't support the worm anymore
you're gonna hit your face on the floor
bleed everywhere knock out a tooth and
ruin denise
you don't have the core for the worm
yeah you do not have it i hate the worm
i hate that guy